regi Aloysius Miller the NBA on TNT
hall-of-famer and no game this week reg
you got the week off I'm Anne and I'm
loving it you see this is why I love
your show
Theodore it is so educational I had no
ideas as well as long as I've known
didn't tell Washington that he played
two years of basketball at Florida I had
no idea and I thought I knew him pretty
well
I had no idea that he was a basketball
player but you were in the movie he got
game you you saw him at least there did
you talk hoops uh I was not in the movie
he got games that was reality no I know
that Ray was in there I thought you had
a scene in there you think spike would
have put me in I got bad info I got some
bad info that I I thought you had a
cameo in there you're right spike
wouldn't have put you in there Paulie
though Reggie Miller is in he got game
they do a clip all these different
players talking about Jesus
Shuttlesworth isn't our clip of Reggie
that's not that's like you're at a green
screen that's not being in the movie
like post-production but you're in the
movie I'm not in them I'm not acting in
the movie they're asking me questions
about a fictitional character Jesus
Shuttlesworth that's not right I'm his
best I'm his best my teammate was in the
movie he stood in the movie
reg if I watched the movie do I see you
okay and maybe he just doesn't remember
he did publicity at least a show that I
was working on spike and Reggie were
together promoting he got game many
years ago I think it was like Center in
New York City
whoa giving out he got game hats with a
black hat with white letters being a
two-year letterman at Florida University
no as I was saying now Denzel said that
he would he would be in for a sequel if
Spike wrote it
what do you think Ray Allen's got time
so you could have Denso the granddad
you could have Ray Ray's the dad and
then you have the Sun and which would be
Steph Curry right yes
yes you would put him in for the the
rayon rule so Ray Allen would be stuck
or he's dead hey I'm coming to get your
record pops
so basically it'd be like true art yes I
like it I'm in I'd love to see ray shoot
against Steph Curry right now just those
two shooting threes just going out on a
court with nobody else there I actually
would pay money to see that I would I
would say would I take ray I wouldn't
take ray right now because Steph doesn't
on the everyday basis but I mean yes
Steph doesn't on the everyday basis but
if you gave ray six months if you get
right up to the all-star break to say
hey we're gonna give a million dollars
to charity on who wins and I'm gonna
repoint competition between you two I
would actually watch and pay for that I
would we're talking a little cooler that
good we're talking to Reggie Miller NBA
on TNT first NBA player you remember
falling in love with you have a poster
up to obviously George the Iceman Gervin
we all have that poster of him sitting
on the blocks of ice with that silver
sweat suit yes and and Jamal Wilkes
those were the two players that I
absolutely loved tried to pattern my
game after when I was a small kid
because both were skinny broke both were
slight George Gervin because of the
finger rolled and growing up in LA in
Riverside and watching the Lakers which
of all Wilkes and that funky shot and
how he used to get it off with defenders
all over him and him playing obviously
at UCLA those were the two players that
I I was like I act I've got to make it
because I want to be just like them have
we seen a game like JoEllen beads can
you think of somebody that has
that kind of footwork talent and can
shoot threes had that athleticism
maybe not shoot threes but obviously the
comparisons to her keep the dream
because of the footwork and a low post
the bigger age game being able to block
shots I don't think the team certainly
could make but not at the point of well
is right now look we're seeing the full
package and I think the next evolution
and step of his game is he's going to
have to play back to backs as great as
he and it to be my only knock will be
he's got to be able to play back to back
games four games in five nights even
though those are somewhat outliers in
our game four games in five nights but I
want to see him play back-to-back nights
you know I want to see how he performs
and you know we used to talk about
Anthony Davis a lot I certainly did and
in you know the transitional game that
he had that he could go in out defense
shoot threes but bothered by injuries
here I don't know if embiid is the is
the future like it can he be one of
those transcendent type players I know
if he stays healthy would you bank on
him or Ben Simmons I would think more on
Ben Simmons just for the simple fact is
I don't know that which is the unknown
of him being able to play you know I
would be happy if indeed played 75 of 82
games and to me that would be a huge
that's a plus but they are holding them
back on all these back-to-back games and
I don't know and Cubs second half of the
season
I still believe Philadelphia is going to
make the playoffs but if there's a
difference between the fourth and fifth
seed or the fifth and sixth seed you're
gonna look back at those games that he
didn't play on those second nights to
factor backs and wonder you know if we
need a game that's going to help in our
seating that we could potentially have
you know home court advantage you're
gonna look back on that are you all in
on the Celtics if I said you had to pick
now the team that comes out of the East
is going to be
I still feel it's very difficult to beat
LeBron James four times in a conference
finals and the only reason why I say
that too is the unknown for them because
I T is not back Isaiah Thomas so until I
see their team at full strength it's
hard for me to be all-in with the
Celtics as remarkable of a run that
they're on right now 15th straight
losing their first to a catastrophic
injury to one of their main players in
Gordon hey work I love what Brad Stevens
and Kyrie is doing its building morale
those young guys at 8'o and brown are
balling but again you've got to beat
LeBron James four times and until
they're at full strength until Isaiah
Thomas is back if he comes back in it's
not the same as a of Thomas he was last
year at Boston that's a different story
but I have to see the Cavs that's full
strength how about your on UCLA football
team it was only a moment of time the
first let me just are saying we're a
basketball school I'm kind of scared to
say that now that we're a basketball
school after everything else I know
oh my god yeah I know
um yeah it's suspected now I want to see
who they're gonna bring in because if
you can recruit LA which USC has done
for the last 25 30 years if you can
recruit LA and get some of these players
to come to UCLA then we can go ahead to
head with se to me in football it's all
about beating FC and they've held the
rights for so many years so I hope they
bring in someone who can recruit LA and
hopefully bring back the football team
to prominence
what would you do with those kids who
were shoplifting in China as a
punishment if you ran what I do or what
will happen what would you do I would
suspend them for the year and I would
let potential recruits their families
and my fan base that
this does not go on at UCLA and I would
not make it a red shirt here and they
will learn from this I have all about
giving young players especially 18 19
year-old second chances which these
players deserve but we need to remember
these same 18 and 19 year olds are the
ones that are going to be first-round
draft picks at number one picks and
making a whole lot of money so people
say oh they're young they're 18 19
no these are the guys that play one year
and make millions of dollars so they
should have known better but you've got
you put your foot down
I would suspend them for one year I
would take off this idiotic indefinite
suspension that's just stupid
mm-hm and I would make it for a full
year and say okay because it's not fair
for the rest of the players let's say
you bring them back for the pac-12
tournament or for the pac-12 season it's
not fair for the rest of the guys every
time you on a road in a road game that's
all you're gonna hear that is all you're
gonna hear you gotta let some time and
distance between what happened to spin
them for the year bring them back next
year and you go from there all will be
forgiven but take off the indefinite
suspension to me that's just crazy now
you got the the president back involved
in this with levar levar ball and they
should have left him in prison over
there and I don't know if this puts
added pressure on UCLA to do something
that levar ball is ungrateful and now
the president has tweeted out that he
shouldn't left him in prison well number
one he wasn't in prison I know he might
have been he might have been headed to
prisons but he wasn't in prison look
it's it's a sticky mess free CLA and
it's very unfortunate that's why you'd
have to suspend these kids for the year
just to let time go by you cannot bring
them back this year because it would
still be a fresh wound and whatever
judgment you you give those people that
are probably listening to this as they
know that's too harsh Reds bring them
back there are only kids there's other
people like take their scholarship away
so check them out I don't believe in
that as well
I believe everyone deserves a second
chance we all are human and we've all
made mistakes
they got literally caught with their
hand in the cookie jar
now you just pay the consequences and
you move on you learn from it that's
what life is about dan you and I have
always made mistakes throughout our
young careers while professional careers
you probably said things on the area you
wish you didn't say I wish I probably
said things on there I didn't wish I
said things happen there's consequences
consequences we get punished for them
and we move on it should all be about
second chances but it should be
suspended for the year and on that note
we say Happy Thanksgiving and you are
you just staying at home and with the
fam I have to take this fan I took the
fam we're down in the desert to get a
little warm air get some technical rock
climbing done on my belt biking and just
relax and have a nice turkey day out
here okay happy turkey day to you and
your family and to my dad net thanks bud
safe travels there and we'll talk to you
next week you're the best my friend
Reggie Aloysius Miller jr. the third for
more Dan Patrick show to the audience
Channel 239 on DirecTV
or download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]